on a aujourd'hui vraiment un match de
champion entre d'un côté le Galaxy S23
ultra et de l'autre côté l'iPhone 15 pro
max on se regarde la partie photo parce
que dans les deux cas vous allez avoir
des smartphones extrêmement performant
mais ce qui peut vraiment faire la
différence c'est ce qui se passe du côté
de la photo et c'est ce qu'on regarde
maintenant sur la partie de gauche on a
le Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra sur la
partie de droite on a l'iPhone 15 pro
max c'est ce qu'on voit tout de suite là
on est sur l'ultra grand angle et bien
c'est que Samsung a une image qui est
toujours plus saturée si vous regardez
le ciel sera plus bleu ici que là et
l'image sera un peu plus chaude du côté
d'Apple un peu plus de jaune qu'on va
venir retrouver ici personnellement ici
j'aime bien les deux c'est vrai que j'ai
une petite préférence en tout cas sur
cette photo sur la photo de Samsung on
passe sur le X 1 le grand angle les deux
images sont très bien bien exposé ça
marche bien il y a rien qui me saute un
peu à l'œil si ce n'est un côté un peu
plus saturé donc un peu plus joli au
côté de l'eau du côté de de Samsung bon
Apple fonctionne bien ensuite on passe
sur un X 2 on va garder exactement la
même chose à chaque fois donc là d'un
côté de l'autre en X 2 et bien je suis
sur un zoom numérique mais ici c'est
pareil la qualité est vraiment préservée
48 mégapixel chez Apple 200 mégapixel
chez Samsung SAMs ça fait le taf là on
est sur le X 3 donc là chez Samsung
voyez on est sur un zoom optique chez
Apple ça reste du numérique mais ça
marche vraiment bien c'est pe-être
légèrement peu plus poussif ici au
niveau du détail ça ressort légèrement
plus de ce côté-là un peu moins ici je
pense qu'il y a un côté un peu numérique
qui va venir un peu fakeer le truc mais
pour moi ici rien de vraiment dérangeant
on va ensuite en X 5 chez Apple on est
sur du zoom optique chez Samsung on est
sur du zoom numérique donc là on voit
qu'on a un petit avantage sur le X 5 du
côté de chez Apple avec un peu plus de
détail ici on en a un peu moins du côté
de chez Samsung ça se joue vraiment à
pas grand-chose hein je préférer les
couleurs qu'on retrouve ici et on va au
x 100 chez Samsung vous êtes sur un x
100 optique chez Apple vous êtes sur un
x 100 numérique mais globalement on
récupère du détail à droite à gauche mis
à part une différence de colorimétrie
dans les deux cas ça fonctionne bien on
continue ici très bonne gestion du
reflet ici sur mon ultra grand angle
bonne gestion de la lumière d'un côté et
de l'autre je trouvais qu'il y a un côté
un peu plus éclatant du côté de chez
Samsung on le VO au niveau du ciel au
niveau de la façade un poil très très
léger un peu plus terne ici du côté de
la prise de vue de iPhone je voit pas
grandchose mais préférence ici pour
Samsung sur le X 1 je vais préférer
également le Galaxy le X 2 on a une
meilleure gestion de l'expo ici voyez du
côté de chez Apple sur la façade là
versus le Galaxy ça se joue pas grand
chose une fois de plus le X 3 ok ça fait
le taf toujours différence un peu ici là
et là le X 5 bon ici je donne le point à
Apple et après on va jusqu'en x 10 ici
où je vais préférer le taf d'Apple sur
cette façade et d'ailleurs j'ai un super
bon plan au lieu de venir acheter votre
iPhone pourquoi ne pas le louer c'est
aujourd'hui grâce à une entreprise
française qui s'appelle nextmobile et
qui vous permet de louer vos iPhone 15
dans les meilleures conditions parce que
c'est pas toujours évident de sortir une
grosse somme d'argent pour venir acheter
son smartphone et bien vous pouvez le
louer très facilement avec next mobile
vous pourrez notamment avoir votre
iPhone 15 au tarif de 44,99 € par mois
ou bien encore votre iPhone 15 plus à
49,99 € par mois votre iPhone 15 pro à
54,99 € par mois et votre iPhone 15 pro
max à 64,99 € par mois et tout ça bien
évidemment sans sans engagement quand on
voit qu'un iPhone 15 pro max vaut à peu
près 1500 € franchement ça vaut le coup
en plus de ça ce qui est génial avec
next mobile c'est que vous pouvez
changer votre smartphone au bout de 12
mois pour la génération suivante ça veut
dire l'iPhone 16 l'année prochaine ihone
16 16 plus 16 pro 16 pro max et tout ça
sans frais caché ni hausse de mensualité
en plus de ça vous avez une tranquillité
d'esprit avec l'assurance casse et vol
inclus surtout quand on sait que quand
on veut venir changer son écran ça peut
rapidement chiffrer jusqu'à 600 €. donc
ça ça vaut aussi vraiment le coup et en
plus de ça NEX mobile un modèle é
coresponsable puisqu'ils vont venir
reconditionner les smartphones en
circuit court en France ils vont donc
pouvoir venir ensuite les louer et leur
donner une seconde vie et en plus de ça
nextmobile va vous faire un petit cadeau
rien que pour vous il vous donne un code
promo exclusif de 20 € valable sur tous
leur site pour venir tester leur
servicees le code c'est mrgux 20
profitez-en je vous mets bien évidemment
un lien juste en bas dans la description
et merci à NEX mobile d'avoir
sponsoriser cette vidéo on va sur un
marché marché couvert lumière
artificielle je trouve que là c'est le
Galaxy qui s'en sort le mieux au niveau
de la teinte des melons au niveau aussi
de tout ce qu'on voit du bois en haut
c'est un peu plus terne du côté de chez
Apple c'est un peu plus froid pour voir
que les iPhone ont une colorimétrie un
peu plus chaude là c'est un peu moins ça
sur le grand angle c'est pareil je vais
venir préférer ce que propose le Galaxy
ici x 2 x 2 x 2 x 3 je préférer la
texture qu'on retrouve là du côté de
chez l'iPhone au niveau du melon là
c'est beaucoup mieux que ce que j'ai ici
sur le Galaxy x 5 pareil texture du côté
du melon je préfère ici et x 10 soyons
clair ici c'est l'iPhone qui remporte le
point toujours en intérieur on va
regarder un peu du côté de la nourriture
donc là je trouve que l'iPhone il a
tendance à foncer légèrement alors que
le Galaxy va faire ressortir un peu plus
ici la pâtisserie pareil de la même
manière je préféris ici le Galaxy voyez
je commence à récupérer un peu de bruit
là légèrement ici mais une fois de plus
je trouve que c'est quand même le
galaxie qui s'en sort le mieux là c'est
bruité préfère ce qu'on retrouve ici sur
le Galaxy c'est quand même vachement
mieux même au niveau de la table
derrière là voyez il y a du bruit c'est
pas ouf là sur la framboise la teinte
est quand même vachement mieux sur le
Galaxy et on se rapprochant énormément
bon ben voilà là il y a le point pour
personne on va regarder sur un autre
angle comme ça là c'est pareil je
préfère vraiment le détail que je
trrouve ici au niveau du Galaxy pareil
le Galaxy quo qu'ici le point voyez il
est pas fait au même endroit j'ai
l'impression qu'il est plus ici sur
l'iPhone que là il est vraiment sur la
framboise là je préfère vraiment les
détails ici sur les pâtisseries l'iPhone
est aux frais et je vais donc donner le
point au Galaxy on a du mode portrait là
je vais préférer ce que fait l'iPhone je
trouve que le Galaxy a tendance à me
faire une peau un peu trop blanche ici
alors après j'aime bien la teinte de la
robe mais le côté légèrement plus chaud
de l'iPhone me plaira davantage ici on
VO qu'on a pas non plus exactement le
même bquet derrière d'un côté et de
l'autre ah j'aime bien quand même cette
teinte de peau là h c'est vraiment une
question de choix non non là je préféré
le boulot de l'iPhone quand même sur ce
mode portrait là ouais là-dessus aussi
je serai plus team iPhone je trouve ça
plus jolie donc sur le mode portrait je
vais plus donner le point l'iPhone ici
là je vais préférer voyz le détail qu'on
va retrouver ici le côté du Buisson au
niveau de l'iPhone je un peu moins
précis ce qu'on a ici du côté du du
Galaxy bon FO la très honnêtement entre
les deux c'est un peu kif kif Bic comme
on dit chez moi on vient se rapprocher
je va il y a un côté un peu plus jaune
voyez c'est bizarre là il y a vraiment
pas du tout le même choix qui est fait
d'un constructeur à l'autre au niveau de
la saturation au niveau du rendu des
couleurs là je suis plus Team Galaxy
quand même
et en venant zoomer là ouais ouais pour
moi ici le boulot ça me paraît plus
intéressant au niveau de la couleur au
niveau de la cohérence je retrouve sur
la gauche au niveau du Galaxy S23 ultra
il y a plus un aspect tableau création
composition qui est très jolie par
rapport à ce que je trrouve de l'autre
côté donc ici je donne le point au
Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra on continue sur
desbécan ici sur l'ultra grand angle je
préféré la couleur qu'on trouve ici là
sur la Kawa en rouge en se rapprochant
voilà une fois de plus je préféré le
boulot donne l'iPhone ici sur les motos
e là je suis en plein doute pas facile
de les départager ces deuxl et là je
suis plus sur le Galaxy j'aime bien le
côté un peu plus froid de l'image le
côté des fois un peu trop chaud je
trouve que c'est un peu trop quoi ouais
même là enant se rapprocher voyez au
niveau du détail ici je va retrouver là
je vois d'avantage de détail ici que là
tout de suite j'en perd un peu plus
ouais là c'est pareil je préféris ce
rendu là légèrement plus froid donc ici
pour moi ça sera le point pour le Galaxy
sur une jolie vue avec un scoot comme ça
alors là je trouve qu'il y a un côté
trop chaud qui fonctionne pas sur
l'iPhone au niveau de la façade sur la
pierre ici voyez même sur le SCO
légèrement trop chaud je vais préférer
le côté une fois de plus un peu plus
froid qu'on retrouve sur le Galaxy ouais
de la même manière sur le fois 1 sur le
xis 2 je suis un peu mitigé j'aime bien
le le SCO comme ça VO quand on est sur
un plan large ou un P un peu plus serré
ça change x 3 je vais voter pour
l'iPhone ouais c'est vrai que là sur les
plans larges je vais préférer tout de
suite le Galaxy mais dès que je me
rapproche j'ai préféré l'iPhone alors
après si on regarde un peu on a un peu
plus de bruit ici qu'on retrouve en
arrière-plan qu'on a pas du côté du
Galaxy en venant zoomer et on le voit
même là voyez il y a beaucoup plus de
bruit sur cette partie là qu'on en a pas
ici donc le Galaxy S23 ultra va être
bien meilleur lorsqu'on va venir zoomer
dedans même si des fois là sur ce plan
là je préfère la colorimétrie de de
l'iPhone mais pour moi c'est bruité
c'est moins bon donc bon ici le point
ira au Galaxy S23 ultra on continue ici
avec ce resto noré cl mon ferrant allez
le voir c'est très bon c'est très bien
vous ferez une bise à Benjamin de ma
part là j'aime bien le côté chaud que
nous ramène l'iPhone avec la cathédrale
en arrière-plan je trouve ça très joli
sur le X 1 et bien ouais je vais plus
comme c'est plus chaud ça va faire
sortir davantage les sièges je plus
aller sur le Galaxy ici voyez il y a
vraiment entre les deux c'est compliqué
quoi de bien faire son choix ouais ok
non ouais et puis une fois de plus il y
a vraiment ce truc qui est important
c'est ce qu'on voit derrière voyez on a
plus de détails c'est plus juste du côté
du Galaxy S23 ultra ça ça vient aussi du
matériel le fait d'avoir double
téléobjectif ça joue énormément et il y
a un moment où l'iPhone a du mal à
rivaliser on ramène du bruit c'est moins
parfait c'est moins JEOL donc ici je
vais donner point à Galaxy S23 ultra on
va aller voir la nuit ce que ça raconte
alors la nuit dans une ruelle à
clamonférence c'est sombre ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous voyez que
l'iPhone vous avez pas cet effet de allo
que vous retrouvez ici sur le S23 ultra
on le retrouve davantage sur la première
lumière un peu sur la deuxième mais
c'est très atténué d'un point de vue
algorithmique sur le l'iPhone tand dis
que Samsung le faire sortir davantage
après il y a aussi un côté un peu plus
éclairé qu'on va retrouver ici sur la
façade par rapport à celui de l'iPhone
donc on a un truc qui est un peu plus
maîtrisé je veux dire dans l'ensemble du
côté de l'iPhone par rapport à ce qu'on
trouve du côté du Samsung Galaxy S23
ultra à côté de ça si vous venez
regarder le détail qu'on a ici au niveau
des pavés et bien on a un peu plus de
détail et de matière par rapport à ce
qu'on a ici et une fois de plus la
façade sur le côté ressort davantage
même si elle est plus bruitée que ce que
nous propose l'iPhone moi je vais quand
même préférer ici dans l'ensemble la
composition nous sur l'iPhone avec le
côté un peu plus foncé sur les côtés un
peu plus clair là au niveau de la
perspective là je vais voter iPhone on
va voir en se rapprochant sur le foisin
par que c'est l'ultra grand angle et on
sait que les ultra grand angle la nuit
ça aime pas trop petit effet de halo
aussi rien de bien déconnant d'un côté
et de l'autre j'aime bien les deux
ambiances je vais préféré en me
rapprochant celle du Galaxy S23 ultra
j'ai bien la façade à l'arrière j'ai
bien ici cette partie là avec la porte
du fond qui fonctionne là j'ai un petit
artefact lumineux ici que je viens
retrouver ici à droite là vous voyez sur
mon iphone que je n'ai pas sur le Galaxy
S23 ultra en me rapprochant je continue
en avoir un petit peu ici sur le côté
que je n'ai pas sur mon galaxy S23 ultra
et en me rapprochant davantage j'en ai
un aussi ici sur le côté que je n'ai pas
sur mon galaxy S23 ultra ah si j'en ai
un petit ici là ça y est j'en ai un qui
apparu ici là j'aime bien la porte là le
détail sur le l'iPhone bon et en venant
zoomer davantage fatalement l'iPhone va
plus souffrir va ramener plus de bruit
mais dans l'ensemble là c'est compliqué
de départager je vais mettre un point au
deux ambiance avec très peu de lumière
également bien c'est la nuit dans un
resto là pour l'instant je vais vraiment
préférer ce que nous propose l'iPhone
avec l'éclair avec le papier qui va
ressortir en arrière par rapport à ce
que j'ai de l'autre côté les marches je
suis un peu moins fan on va regarder par
la suite sur le FO je vais aussi
préférer l'iPhone la compou de l'image
est un peu différente mais je vais quand
même préférer un peu l'iPhone ça ressort
comme ça au niveau des couleurs j'aime
bien en venant me rapprocher je vais
trouver que l'iPhone va mieux soutenir
les couleurs dans le tableau ici qu'on
retrouve donc bon je préférer le boulot
que nous rend l'iPhone là-dessus là
c'est pareil l'iPhone on vient zoomer
ouais pareil je vais préférer la
saturation que nous propose ici et le
rendu global de l'image au niveau de
l'iPhone bon en venant zoomer davantage
une fois de plus j'ai préféré ici ce que
nous propose ihone donc là c'est un
point pour l'iPhone 15 pro max photo de
nuit encore voyez un vrai parti prix qui
est différent entre d'un côté l'iPhone
qui va un peu plus tamiser certains
endroits pour faire ressortir que
l'endroit où il y a de la lumière tandis
que le Galaxy S23 ultra essaie de tout
éclairer qu'on voit d'avantage la
gestion de la lumière est plutôt bonne
des deux côtés et voyez là ça s'inverse
là je vais plus préférer ce que nous
propose ici le Galaxy S23 ultra je
trouvaé que c'est un peu plus FAD un peu
plus pâle du côté de l'iPhone 15 pro max
et ça se joue vraiment à pas grandchose
là voyez dès qu'on zoome un peu plus je
viens vraiment voter plus pour le Galaxy
S23 ultra là au niveau du détails et de
l'araignée il y a des belles araignées
là-dedans ouais ça se vaut bon là j'ai
donné le point à l'iPhone pour la
composition global on va pas trop venir
zoomer la nuit de toute façon même si
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on vient zoomer on
voit qu'il y a du bruit un peu à droite
à gauche et là il va commencer à
souffrir davantage on revient le jour
qu'est-ce que ça nous raconte ici le
ciel bien maîtrisé un peu plus froid du
côté du S23 ultra on voit un peu plus
les détails dans les arbres ici on un
peu moins ici sur l'iPhone une fois de
plus pareil voyez au niveau du
traitement de l'image sur le Galaxy on a
un peu mieux de détail au niveau de
l'arbre sur le côté qu'on en a un petit
peu moins ici sur l'iPhone le ciel ça va
des deux côtés ça fonctionne facè du
bâtiment je le préféré sur l'iPhone ici
en venant zoomer là pour l'instant comme
ça ça fonctionne pareil comme ça ici je
préféré le traitement quand même du
Galaxy S23 ultra et vous voyez hein là
c'est c'est sans appel dès qu'on vient
zoomer un moment l'iPhone peut pas aller
bien plus loin on souffre au niveau de
la la forêt derrière ici ça fonctionne
le clocher ressort davantage de l'église
des Minimes que là il ressort pas
énormément donc il y a un moment on voit
très bien que l'iPhone a des limites ça
reste un très bon photophone mais le
Galaxy S23 ultra reste quand même
beaucoup plus polyvalent voyez là je
viens zoomer davantage ouis là tout de
suite il a beaucoup plus de mal et avec
le Galaxy S23 ultra je peux aller jusque
là alors je suis sur un Space zoom x 100
très honnêtement la qualité est pas du
tout au rendez-vous donc on va pas y
aller mais on peut venir le faire donc
c'est vrai que sur cette image là sur le
côté purement zoom téléobjectif je vais
fatalement donner le point au Galaxy S23
ultra là on vient chercher la cathédrale
claront Ferrand là c'est pareil au
niveau de l'image j' vais préférer qu' y
a un côté plus tonique du côté du Galaxy
S23 ultra au niveau des teintes au
niveau des couleurs au niveau des arbres
au niveau des détails que je trouve
l'iPhone un peu plus plat ici voyez là
le bleu ressort davantage là il ressort
un petit peu moins et ça manque un peu
de dynamique j'ai l'impression du côté
de chez Apple là et en foisin là c'est
pareil je vais préférer le rendu du
Galaxy S23 ultra là c'est pareil sur la
façade là ça ressort davantage là c'est
un peu plus terne en venant zoomer ici
c'est pareil j'ai préféré ce que nous
propose le Galaxy S23 ultra là c'est
pareil là l'iPhone s'en sort pas mal là
vous voyez là s'en sort quand même pas
mal ça c'est vraiment bien il faut le
voir ah c'est pas mal là ce que nous
propose Apple mais là vous voyez dès
qu'on vient zoomer davantage bon ben on
est au fraises du côté de de l'iPhone il
y a du bon oui c'est moins précis moins
de détail moins netteté et tout de suite
le Galaxy S23 ultra s sortira quand même
beaucoup mieux là je vais pas m'arrêter
que sur le côté téléobjectif mais sur le
côté ambiance globale je trouve que le
Galaxy S23 ultra s'en sort quand même
vachement mieux sur une photo comme ça
c'est beaucoup plus joli il y a plus de
couleur c'est plus saturé plus soutenu
plus de détails donc ici je donne le P
Galaxy S23 ultra are photo place de J à
Clermont regardez là c'est intéressant
au niveau de l'arbre on a un peu plus de
détail ici que tout de suite c'est
beaucoup plus foncé du côté de l'iPhone
je préfère le côté un peu plus saturé de
l'image avec la statue de vcent Goris
qui va sortir un peu plus ici je la
trouve un peu sort d'avantage c'est plus
terne en fait j'ai l'impression que
l'ultra grand angle là qu'on retrouve
tout de suite en tout cas sur le
l'iPhone 15 pro max c'est un peu plus
terne le fait que ça soit un peu plus
saturé ça permet de déboucher un peu
plus l'image ici que là ça ressort un
peu moins bien alors il y a peut-être
plus de bleu à ce moment-l il se peut
que ça aille bouger un peu au niveau de
la masse mais c'est pareil s'il faut
regarder sur la porte qu'on retrouve ici
on va plus de bleu que là c'est un peu
plus grisé ça ressort moins c'est moins
joli là pareil au niveau du FO je trouve
que ça ressort davantage au niveau du
clocher au niveau du bleu qu'on rrouve
là ouis il y a quand même pour moi une
supériorité là c'est pareil au niveau de
cette façade de ce bâtiment là je trouve
légèrement plus terne aussi sur le
détail au niveau des feuilles ici statue
de veretoric c'est pareil elle ressort
davantage sur galaxy S23 ultra en venant
zoomer pour moi c'est pareil la
colorimétri elle joue quand même
vachement ici je trouve qu'en fait en
ayant un côté un peu trop chaud un peu
plus chaud ça rend les photos un peu
plus ternes et moi ça me parle beaucoup
moins vous voyez en venant me rapprocher
Galaxy S23 ultra sans aucun doute pour
moi ici aussi sans appel alors après on
vient zoomer donc fatalement il va
souffrir davantage on peut aller
jusqu'au space zoom une fois de plus le
Space zoom c'est pas ouf mais quand on
vient se rapprocher la qualité est là et
surtout ce qui est intéressant c'est une
fois de plus ce choix colorimétrique qui
pour moi fait la différence au niveau
des images donc ici je donne le point
aussi au Galaxy S23 ultra je vais
préférer l'iPhone sur cet ultra grand
angle là e là c'est peu plus difficile
he plus difficile à départager mais là
l'iPhone sen sort quand même vachement
mieux je sais pas où il a fait le point
lui devant parce que c'est un peu plus
flou derrière que lui c'est un peu plus
net là c'est net là ça fonctionne là ça
fonctionne parce que comme on est sur
une pierre un peu plus chaude le côté un
peu plus chaud de l'iPhone va
fonctionner sur cette pierre qui est
légèrement pas un peu jaune mais dans
les côtés un peu plus brun là c'est
pareil ça me va là l'iPhone me plaît
bien làdessus là c'est pareil ça me
plaît aussi mais là voyez ce côté pierre
chaude sur des édifices sur sur des
bâtiments comme ça très anciens ça
fonctionne vraiment du côté de l'iPhone
bon après il y a un moment où le Space
zoom va tout rattraper il fa qu'on aura
plus de détails lorsquon vient
énormément zoomer mais malgré tout ici
je donnais le point à l'iPhone parce que
je trouve que sur des bâtiments comme ça
là en tout cas dans cette photo là il
s'en sort quand même vachement bien ici
là l'iPhone c'est pareil je trouve qu'il
est plus net au niveau de l'ultra grand
angle ah ici je suis un peu emmerdé
j'arrive pas à départager que les deux
sont sont quand même pas mal compliqué
de départager ici vraiment sur les deux
photos on vient se rapprocher là ah
ouais là j'ai vraiment du mal là j'aime
bien le côté un peu plus chaud de
l'iPhone sur la barique ça fonctionne
bien sur la façade ça fonctionne bien
bon après il y a un moment où forcément
ils vont avoir du mal en venant rezomer
avec la vitrine ça va être dur et on
peut aller beaucoup plus loin avec le
Galaxy S23 ultra donc ici compliqué de
les départager je vais mettre un point
en deux le smartphone qui va sortir
mieux au niveau de la photo entre d'un
côté le Galaxy S23 ultra et l'autre côté
l'iPhone 15 pro max et bien c'est le
Galaxy S23 ultra qui est pour moi ici le
meilleur photophone entre les deux alors
soyons clair l'iPhone 15 pro max reste
un très bon photophone mais en terme de
polyvalence en terme de rendu le fait
d'avoir ce double téléobjectif va quand
même emmener le Galaxy S23 ultra plus
loin que ce que peut faire ici l'iPhone
15 pro Max qui pour autant reste un bon
photophone mais il y a aussi un truc qui
moi me plaît un peu moins c'est le fait
que l'image tire un peu trop sur le
jaune du côté de l'iPhone et bien moi ça
va moins m'emporter je préférer un côté
un peu plus froid un peu plus bleu du
Galaxy S23 ultra je vais trouver
également que le Galaxy S23 ultra sera
des fois un peu meilleur au niveau du
détail sans forcément all dans le
téléobjectif sans forcément aller loin
mais il sera meilleur au niveau du
détail il sera meilleur au niveau de la
colorimétrie il arrivera davantage à
réhausser certaines scènes alors il est
pas parfait hein c'est pas non plus un
100 %
mais à venir choisir et à comparer ici
entre ces deux photophones fait partie
des deux meilleurs smartphones du marché
et bien mon choix ici va se porter sur
le Galaxy S23 ultra même si une fois de
plus l'iPhone 15 pro max reste un très
bon photophone et d'ailleurs si vous
voulez tout savoir sur ce Galaxy S23
ultra allez voir ma vidéo de test et
vous verrez que au-delà de la photo ce
Galaxy S23 Ultra est aussi très très bon
dans d'autres domaines mais ça je vous
laisse aller voir cette vidéo pour tout
savoir